[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERICA CHUONG: Hi, everyone.
I'm Erica Chuong, a partner
engineer at Google Cloud.
Welcome back to Google Cloud
Technical Guides for Startups,
where we're creating a series of
videos for technical enablement
to help startups set up their
own Google Cloud platform
environment and grow their
businesses successfully
and sustainably on Google Cloud.
This episode focuses on
setting up billing and alerts
and optimizing costs on
Google Cloud, which I know
is everyone's favorite topic.
The good news is Google Cloud
makes billing management
and optimization really easy.
In this video, we're going to
cover Google Cloud resources,
billing administration,
discounting,
and additional resources.
So without any
further ado, let's
get right on into exploring the
Google Cloud platform together.
If you're new to
Google Cloud, please
refer to video 2 of
the series, which
discusses Google Cloud
resources, organizations,
and permissions.
These concepts will be
important when it comes
to billing administration.
A billing admin is responsible
for much more than just
making sure invoices get paid.
They're also responsible for
managing payment instruments,
configuring billing exports,
viewing cost information,
and managing user roles
on the billing account.
The way Cloud computing
is charged and billed,
it's a little of a shift
in mindset from what
most companies are used to.
Instead of one-and-done
data center purchases,
billing is done monthly
and is consumption-based.
Managing cost becomes
a little bit different,
which we'll get into when we
discuss budgets and alerts.
In order to connect a
project to a billing account,
you need to have the
correct permissions granted
on both the project and
billing account levels.
The minimum roles required
include billing account user
on the billing account and
project billing manager
on the project or
resource associated.
Higher permissions,
such as project owner,
will work as well but
are unnecessary due
to least-privilege design.
While on the topic
of permissions,
it's important to note that
when a new billing account is
created, the user creating it is
usually also given the payment
profile admin role on
the payment profile.
If you do need to change
the billing account admin
role to someone else
for whatever reason,
remember to also change the
payment profile admin rule.
So what is a billing
account specifically?
A billing account is essentially
how you pay for projects.
Projects can exist
without a billing account
thanks to the free tier that
many Google products have,
but you're limited to quotas.
To fully operate, a project
must have a billing account
associated to it.
A billing account is just where
costs and charges are bucketed.
And this also represents a
customer's legal relationship
with Google.
The billing account is then both
a legal and financial entity--
an organization compared
to billing account
with the organization and
contractual obligation
between Google and the customer
exists at the billing account
level.
There are two types
of billing accounts.
There's invoiced or offline.
And that just refers to accounts
that are invoiced on net terms,
typically 30 days, and have
a signed contract associated.
There's also
self-serve or online,
and that refers to
accounts that sign up
in a self-service
manner with a credit
card, debit card,
or bank transfer
and are charged when
payment becomes due.
Most organizations will have
a single billing account,
but some may have multiple.
Generally, if you
have multiple, it's
due to legal or
accounting reasons,
or maybe they need to pay
in multiple currencies.
Something to keep in mind is
that having multiple billing
accounts can mean
additional overhead
and could make things
tricky to track and manage
depending on how many you have.
So just be cognizant
of that before you
start setting up multiple.
A project could only be
assigned to one billing account,
but a billing account can be
tied to multiple projects.
A billing account is managed
through the Google Cloud
Console.
A billing account is specific
to Google Cloud resources,
but there is another resource
called a payments profile,
which I mentioned earlier, which
is a general Google billing
resource and applicable for
other services such as Maps
and Ads.
Your billing account is linked
to your payment profile.
You can see and manage
everything at pay.google.com.
This is essentially
just a collection
of payment information
such as mailing addresses
and forms of payments for
the organization as a whole.
So let's take a look at what
this looks like in the Console
itself.
This is the interface
of a billing account.
The billing ID is at the top.
This is automatically
generated for you.
You have your billing admin.
You can have multiple here.
This person can add
additional admins and users
and assign permissions directly
on the billing account.
Each project you create will
be linked to a billing account.
And here you can also
see which projects
are linked to that
particular billing account.
When you create
a new project, it
will ask you which
billing account
you'd like to associate.
You can also suspend a project
to stop billing at any time.
Something to keep in mind
is that projects and billing
accounts do not necessarily need
to be in the same organization.
As long as the user has
the correct permissions
to set up the relationship
between the billing
account and a project,
they could be anywhere.
So you could manage things
cross-organizationally as well.
So now that you have your
resources and billing accounts
set up and running,
you may be wondering,
how do I see what
resources says I'm using
and where are my largest
costs coming from?
That's relatively easy,
and there are a few ways
that you can do this.
So first, you have your Cloud
Console billing reports.
These are going to give
you general information
on your spend, and they're
ready to go, ready-made.
Examples here.
Another option is
your monthly invoice.
This will show you details
of consumption associated
with a billing account.
Depending on how many
resources you've consumed,
your bill could
be quite lengthy.
So it might be a
lot to sift through.
Another option is to
build a customized billing
dashboard in
BigQuery, Data Studio,
or a BI tool of your choice.
This will give you more
granular reporting, analysis,
and visibility and allow you to
really slice and dice your data
and derive insights from it.
So let's take a look
at an example of one
of these dashboards
built in Data Studio.
So a Data Studio
dashboard such as this one
can give you a more visual
view of your billing.
This dashboard has multiple
different views to give you
different levels of detail.
The first is going to
be our GCP cost summary.
We can see we have year-to-date
costs, quarter-to-date costs,
month-to-date costs.
We also see trends month over
month, change in dollars.
You can also add visuals
such as pie charts
to allow you to easily
slice and dice your data
and see how much of each
service is contributing
to your overall bill.
You can also filter
based on labels.
In this particular
dashboard, we've
added granularity on the team,
Google Cloud platform service,
and environment levels.
So environment could also just
be production and deployment.
So let's take a look at
our cost-by-team view.
So once this loads,
we can see that we
have four different teams.
And with this, we can get
granularity pretty easily.
So very quickly, I can see
that almost 50% of billing
is by the pso team, 33% is
by the engineering team,
and 16% is by the
networking team.
Over on the right-hand
side, we also
have a trend
analysis to which we
can see how our data is
moving over a time basis.
At the top, we
also have filters.
So if I wanted to filter by
date range, metric, project,
or GCP service, those
are options as well.
Again, slice and dice for data.
The same views can be seen on
an environment basis as well.
These labels were created
on the project level
and were included in the
queries used to export the data.
So currently, we only
have one environment.
It's production in this case.
But we can very easily see that
we've accrued a cost of $827.
And same thing as
we saw before, we
have a graph on the
right-hand side that
shows our trend analysis.
This is actually
a premade template
that you can re-use with
your own billing export data.
And there are
instructions on how
to do so within the
bottom tab right here.
Next is managing
our monthly spend.
So we really want to remain
on target to see where we are,
and that's where budgets
and alerts come in.
So alerts are important to avoid
any sort of billing surprises.
And you can set up
multiple alert percentages
to get notifications as
usage continues to increase.
So for example,
if I wanted to be
notified when I reached 50%,
75%, and 90% of my budget,
I can do so.
You can set notifications
up in your email,
or you can set them
to automatically take
action using Pub/Sub, Cloud
Functions, or Cloud Run.
This could include
shutting down a resource,
or changing your resource
usage, or sending notifications
to a ticketing system
such as ServiceNow.
There's also a forecast trigger.
So this will allow
you to be notified
as soon as you are
forecasted to reach a budget
by the end of the month.
This allows you to
make changes to lower
your spend if needed and is
a much more proactive rather
than reactive response.
So as mentioned when I showed
that Data Studio dashboard,
labels can help you manage
Cloud applications at scale.
So they offer clarity
into resources being used
and can help deploy,
monitor, and manage
at an individual
application level.
They can give visibility into
usage by department or group
and help with cost control
and resource management.
So we all love discounts
and optimization.
And here are just
a few ways to do so
within your GCP environments.
So CUDs, or Committed
Use Discounts,
allow users to prebuy in bulk.
Committed Use Discounts
are ideal for workloads
with predictable resource needs.
When you purchase a
Committed Use Discount,
you purchase Compute
Engine resources
such as vCPUs, memory, GPUs,
local SSDs, and sole tenant
nodes at a discounted
price in return
for committing to paying
for those resources for one
or three years.
The discount is up to
57% for most resources
like machine types and GPUs.
The discount can also
be up to a whopping 70%
for memory-optimized
machine types.
For Cloud SQL, it's a
little bit different.
You commit to a
consistent amount
of usage measured in dollars
per hour of equivalent on-demand
spend for a one or
three-year term.
In exchange, you receive
a discounted rate
on the applicable usage
your commitment covers.
So you can purchase
Committed Use Discounts
from any Cloud billing account.
And the discount applies to any
eligible usage on projects paid
for by that billing account.
Any sort of overages are then
charged at an on-demand rate.
There's also Sustained
Use Discounts,
and these are one of GCPs larger
points of differentiation.
So this is basically
a large discount
on Compute Engine
resources for workloads
that are run for a significant
portion of the month.
There's also preemptible VMs.
And this is another
great way to lower costs
if you have workloads that
are fault-tolerant and can
withstand possible
instance preemptions.
Discounts for these
can be up to 80%.
I suggest talking
to your sales team
to see how you can
optimize your environment
and really take advantage
of any applicable discounts.
So with that, we have tons
of resources and guides
around setting up billing
on our documentation site.
I highly encourage
you to take a look
prior to setting everything
up in your own environment.
Should you run into any issues,
our billing support team
is always available as well.
A couple of resources have been
added to the description box
below to help you
understand these concepts
in further detail.
So please check them out.
This brings us to
the end of the video
where we covered Google Cloud
resources, billing admin,
discounting, and
additional resources.
Stay tuned for all of
the exciting content
that we have in store for you.
And don't forget to
like and subscribe
on our YouTube channel.
Click on the bell icon
to be notified each time
a new video is posted, and
we will see you very soon
in our next video.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]